what would you say to Jed and what would
you say to Hanna about all this Jed all
that I really wanted was a phone call
this is a show to the general population
and everyone's watching me display out
on national television this was not real
why I have no I'm watching or hearing
about this on spoiler counts with the
recipe but while the rest of the country
is finding out about this you know Sara
Lee
I don't know this that phone call
would've been nice some sort of
explanation would have been nice yeah
and I get that yeah you know the thing
is like with Hanna people keep saying
like did you have no regard for her I
didn't know I just someone told me they
loved me this is what's best for them I
trusted in that this is what the
situation would be I mean ever known you
know feelings would be involved or their
hearts would be broken I know that this
story is hurtful to her and she's
feeling what I have felt and that is not
an easy thing to do or know that I've
done you know it's easy so many people
are tied up because if Hanna and Jed
have ended up together at the end of
this how will you feel guys this is the
person that I love that could just be
engaged to do something else so that's
not easy but you know if they are you
know that's right yeah it's really all
that I couldn't so any message you would
have for Hanna then feature yourself I
mean she's confident she's held her own
from everything that I've seen and heard
and read she is holding her own